hi I'm Erik Bosse and Star Wars the last
Jedi gave us so much to talk about it's
perhaps the most daring and surprising
of the Star Wars Canon whoa I'm already
saying too much spoilers ahead if you
haven't seen the last Jedi in fact I'm
gonna go watch it again to give you some
time to pause and watch or if you just
want to scram and save yourself okay
seriously serious seriously I'm going to
discuss some major plot points in this
video so go watch a movie okay as I said
the last Jedi had so many twists and
bulled directions maybe we felt a little
whiplash especially if he sat in the
front row like I did perhaps the biggest
twist of the movie was kylo ren's
decision to and last chance to avoid
spoilers kylo ren's decision to kill
Supreme Leader Snoke so big question why
exactly does kylo do this I should start
by saying this dynamic between Snoke Rey
and Kaila was one of my favorite scenes
in the movie there were definitely some
parallels to Return of the Jedi
with race rendering herself a loan to
kylo and Snoke open to turn kylo back to
the light just like Luke aim to do with
Vader in Jedi and like Vader with
Emperor Palpatine kylo suddenly betrays
this old man or whatever it was say V in
the hero for being tortured and
ultimately killed the difference is kylo
makes his decision for very very
different reasons whereas Vader killing
Palpatine was all about redemption and
finding the compassion still deep inside
him kylo killing Snoke was all about
power and controlling his destiny
earlier in the scene Snoke revealed that
he was behind the pseudo telepathic link
between ray and kylo that we saw
throughout the movie with an arrogant
laughs no dismisses kylo is a mere pawn
and his master plan it's also
interesting what word choice kylo uses
in the scene as Snoke orders him to kill
ray and fulfill his destiny kylo tells
Rey I know what I have to do notice that
gray gives them this look of recognition
like hey I've heard that before
I just re-watched Force awakens to dummy
yeah this is exactly what kylo says to
Han right before he gutted him in force
awakens' know what I have to do but I
don't know if I have the strength to do
it it's almost like kylo signalling the
Ray and definitely to us that the thing
that he knows he has to do is the
opposite of what we're expecting him to
do in the moment but really it connects
to kylos
overall Ark as a character he killed Han
because he felt his father was holding
them back and early in the last Jedi he
smashes the helmet he designed to evoke
Darth Vader because he realized that
that emulation was also restraining him
and making him weak now killing Snoke is
the third step of kylos violent
separation from his past he doesn't want
to fulfill the destiny that Snoke has
laid out for him
Snoke is as this kid on a leash ever
since he was training with Luke and this
pooch just wants to be free kylo says to
raise short-term this concept of
breaking free from the past from legend
is really the core theme of the last
Jedi where Rey it's letting go of her
childish bedtime story of the great Luke
Skywalker as a chivalrous hero and Jedi
Master and the idea that her parents
might be anyone important or care about
coming back to her for Luke it's letting
go of the remnants of the Jedi Order and
his fear of creating another monster and
for us the viewers it's releasing this
Star Wars series from the icons of the
previous generation but yeah for kylo
killing the past means literally killing
his master replacing him as the new
supreme leader for the first-order so
yeah well it's kind of a bummer that we
never learn about Snuggs backstory Snoke
was never intended to be the real
villain of this new trilogy instead he
was designed as yet another obstacle for
kylo to clear to reach his full
villainous potential and it is great
that his first order of business is to
join rey against the Praetorian guards
perhaps the best benefit of this
newfound freedom by kylo it's one of the
coolest lightsaber scenes ever guys if
you think about it it's another slap in
the face to snow kylo is proving that he
actually gained something personal from
this manipulated play date series not
just someone to get him access to Luke
Skywalker a potential partner for him to
work with and I gotta hand it to these
new movies for portraying lightsaber
deaths with the truly gruesome
impalement that real sword fighting
would have when you inevitably re-watch
the last Jedi pay close attention to the
way Johnson shoots snoke's death now you
may see a connection with the
mid-section Severine of darth maul and
the phantom menace but i don't recall
that movie really lingering on the death
this movie gives us this creepy close-up
of snoke's miss shapen skull drooling on
the ground afterward and notice how the
lightsaber blade also severs snoke's
hand which must have been like lined up
with his hip or something it just stays
perched on the armrest like a thing in
the Addams Family I love this detail
because if you think about it this way
even if snoke's
top half could still survive for a brief
moment you would still not be able to
use his hand to attack them either it's
like kylos mutilating Snoke in just the
right way it's gonna get question for
you guys did kylo killing Snoke make him
more of a hero in your eyes or even more
of a villain comment down below with
your thoughts or tweet me directly at da
Vox and following the rockstars on
Twitter at new rockstars for updates on
her videos and keep an eye out for more
last Jedi videos that we got in the
works including a super in-depth
breakdown of all the admissible details
and cameos and easter eggs only visual
choices and influences that I love from
this movie of course subscribe to new
rockstars for analyses and deep dives
into Star Wars and all the stuff that
you love and if you really like us we
would much appreciate it if you could
contribute to us on patreon big thanks
to all our donors especially the great
Kelly hopper thanks for watching guys
bye